let's see let's go to the 209 area code
who's calling today from 2:09 hey David
this is Cameron hey Cameron what's going
on well you guys yeah a lot of good
calls today actually I'm actually kind
of not exactly sure what exactly to ask
but I did want to I basically wanted to
get your opinion on what I think is who
I think are they're like the real
frontrunners for the Democrat Party and
that would be Bernie Sanders of course
what exactly do you think are is a bit I
think he's like by far the frontrunner I
don't think anyone comes both even by
believability hasn't announced I just
think Sanders has far more support what
do you think are the biggest obstacles
in his way from winning the nomination
okay so Bernie Sanders right now has a
plurality of Democratic support if you
don't count Joe Biden on the basis of
the polling the question is going to be
can he consolidate that support and can
he get the support he needs in certain
states that are early in the primary
process so if Bernie continues polling
twenty percent twenty twenty five
percent into the first primaries that
certainly means he's going to start
picking up delegates right away the
question is will he win enough states
because just getting some delegates in a
bunch of states
it'll keep you in the race for a while
but it won't win you the race so I don't
want to play in the sort of stereotypes
around this but like South Carolina is
an example there's a contingent that
says Bernie's not doing well with black
people so he's not going to do well in
South Carolina the polling actually does
not suggest that but let's pretend that
that were true for a second if South
Carolina comes and goes and Bernie
doesn't do well every time that happens
it starts to make it a bigger and bigger
obstacle to overcome to ultimately get
more delegates than anybody else right
right III think you can actually win
like deep red states like West Virginia
because he did beat Hillary in the
primaries in that state I'm just
concerned because the media doesn't seem
to
be as harsh I in my opinion to him as
before because I think he has this giant
you know giant band of support but um I
I'm not sure because I can see if you
see what they're clearly doing to Tulsi
Gabbard right now who I think is just as
strong it's not as strong as well maybe
like almost as strong as Bernie Sanders
but on what thing you have beta we are
you are you basing that on polling
fundraising because I don't see her
nearly as strong as Bernie on any of
those well I mean like when it comes
when it comes to her she her composure
her rhetoric her her platform and how
because I talk to a lot of conservative
friends and they seem to if they would
give him the opportunity like if she got
the nomination that they would
absolutely vote for me mostly due to her
or nominees interfaces interventionist
policies and and you know along that
yeah yeah I just disagree so I say so
I'm hearing you like her rhetoric but on
what matters which i think is
favorability polling and fundraising I
don't think she's nearly as strong as I
think I think I'm we'll see what happens
got you know I got a point made I got a
run but I appreciate the phone call we
will see ultimately what happens with
Bernie Sanders and on that note I've got
to go to a break sorry to everybody I
didn't get to but I will take phone
calls again next week